moment pour moi très important mes chers
collègues
mesdames messieurs je vous remercie de
tout coeur pour votre confiance pour
cette confiance que vous me témoignez en
me portant aujourd'hui à la présidence
de notre conseil départemental
j'en suis d'autant plus touchés qu'à
travers ce choix leur a fait désormais
partie de la petite dizaine de
départements qui ont décidé de placer
une femme à leur tête
vous pouvez en être convaincu je mettrai
toute ma détermination et toute mon
énergie au service du haut rang de ces
territoires et de ses habitants nous
sommes tous unis je vais trop vite parce
que je ne peux plus je suis appelé je
sais pas ce que ça c'est un paragraphe
important je sais que je ne serai pas
seul je ne serai pas seul pour affronter
les défis à venir
je suis entouré d'une belle équipe
d'élus vous tous chers collègues belle
équipe d'élus volontaire et compétent
avec lesquels je partage bon nombre
d'engagements d'ambition et de priorités
nous sommes tous unis par une volonté
très forte celle de construire ensemble
lui aura de demain nous le ferons oui
avec rigueur et efficacité mais aussi
avec tout l'esprit d'ouverture et
d'innovation requis pour surmonter les
défis qui se présenteront à nis en
particulier ceux liés à nos contraintes
budgétaires
oui nous partageons tous la foi en un
département fort
fort de ces atouts et fier fier de son
identité en département dont nous
connaissons chaque parcelle de
territoire et chaque acteur qu'il soit
public
privé économique ou associatif oui nous
croyons en un département dynamique
solidaire est proche des attentes de ses
concitoyens une collectivité porteuse
des valeurs de la république
résolument ancré dans le rhin supérieur
est profondément enraciné dans sa région
historique l'alsace
cette fois cette fois c'est celle qui
nous a amenés à nous présenter aux
dernières élections
alors qu'on annonçait pourtant la mort
prochaine des départements mais cette
fois c'est aussi celle que nous avons pu
acquérir au fil des travaux menés
ensemble lors des deux dernières années
sous la conduite d'eric straumann au nom
de nous tous au nom de chacune et chacun
d'entre nous je tiens publiquement à
rendre hommage à la pertinence et à la
qualité de la gestion des risques
straumann merci à toi cher eric
[Applaudissements]
oui je suis fier d'assurer cette
succession avec vous je poursuivrai des
démarches engagées pour l'indispensable
stabilisation des finances
départementales
toujours dans le respect du contribuable
avec vous je continuerai également à
veiller à l'adaptation constante de nos
politiques et à la modernisation de
notre administration concernant
l'administration
je tiens à saluer le dévouement et la
compétence de nos cadres et
collaborateurs fortement mobilisée par
notre directeur général des services
philippe jamet à qui j'accorde toute ma
confiance
ils seront dans les gage de notre
réussite
nos agents restent les premiers garants
du service public de qualité et de
proximité que nous et lui souhaitons
mettre en oeuvre pour nos administrés et
nos usagers fort de ses solides
fondations financières et humaines
nous allons pouvoir mener chers
collègues les nouvelles actions qui
s'inscrivent dans notre feuille de route
vers 2021
l'emploi l'emploi doit constituer la
première de nos priorités
malgré la petite embellie récemment
constatés dans le haut rhin les chiffres
du chômage en alsace reste vraiment
alarmant 155 mille chômeurs toutes
catégories confondues et continue de
croître
cette problématique de l'emploi est
transversal à toutes nos compétences
nous devons constamment évolué évalué
évaluer et rien que roger nos décisions
en référence à cet objectif fondamental
nous pourrons alors jouer un rôle moteur
dans ce domaine seront évidemment
concerné en premier lieu nos politiques
en faveur de l'insertion professionnelle
mais également par exemple nos
interventions en faveur du bénévolat et
du multilinguisme qui sont autant de
facteurs d'employabilité pour nos
concitoyens
une attention toute particulière sera
également accordée à notre jeunesse
oui nous avons une ardente obligation
celle de lui faire bénéficier de tous
les moyens nécessaires à son
épanouissement et au développement de sa
conscience citoyenne
il faudra mettre en oeuvre une véritable
stratégie de réussite éducative qui
passera par l'équipement de nos collèges
mais aussi par une mise en convergence
de nos politiques éducatives culturelles
sportives et sociales le jeune le mérite
l'alsace aussi d'autres initiatives nous
permettront bien entendu de rester des
acteurs déterminés et engagés en matière
de développement durable d'aménagement
équilibré de nos territoires et surtout
de solidarité qui sera toujours au coeur
de notre mission
parmi nos ambitions communes il y a
aussi la nécessité impérieuse de rendre
à l'alsace sa capacité à être maîtresse
de son destin
c'est en lui ménageant la possibilité de
s'ouvrir sur le monde et de valoriser
tous ses atouts que nous permettront à
notre région de retrouver sa prospérité
mon histoire personnelle mon parcours
politique
mes expériences professionnelles ont
forgée en moi une conviction très
profonde
quand l'alsace pourra jouer pleinement
son rôle au coeur de l'espace
trinationale elle deviendra oui elle
deviendra un atout majeur pour le
développement économique de la france
d'ici 2020 tiens il faudra tout mettre
en oeuvre en concertation avec les
parlementaires et en collaboration très
étroite avec le conseiller départemental
du bas-rhin pour convaincre le
gouvernement de cette opportune
en obtenant de sa part le droit pour
l'alsace d'expérimenter d'expérimenter
une nouvelle organisation politique
c'est un pari gagnant gagnant pour
l'alsace et pour la france qui se
réalisera dans cette perspective nous
accélérons le rapprochement de nos
politiques avec celles de nos voisins
bas rhinois nous serons également très
actif à l'égard de deux facteurs
essentiels du développement de notre
région à savoir la coopération
transfrontalière et le bilinguisme
nous le savons chers collègues il nous
faudra une détermination de tous les
instants que ce soit pour défendre
l'alsace pour affronter les futurs défis
budgétaires ou pour promouvoir les
valeurs de solidarité et de citoyenneté
au sein de notre société
ceci est d'autant plus vrai que nous ne
serons jamais vraiment à l'abri de
telles ou telles initiatives
gouvernementales qui impactera nos
finances les récentes décisions sur les
contrats aidés sont là pour nous le
rappeler
cette nouvelle aventure sera forcément
exaltante
chers collègues et j'y suis prête car
comme mon grand-père joseph rey qui a
siégé au conseil général du haut rhin de
1945 à 1980 deux géants moi la force de
mes valeurs et de mes convictions et
comme le disait simone veil je ne suis
pas de ceux et de celles qui redoutent
l'avenir nous non plus chers collègues
j'en suis convaincu nous serons donc
ensemble tous ensemble à la hauteur de
nos responsabilités et des attentes de
nos concitoyens
je vous remercie une nouvelle fois de
votre confiance et vous propose à
présent de passer à l'ordre du jour de
la réunion mais avant cela j'invite les
collèges 1er 2ème 3ème vice-président et
le
directeur général des services à bien
vouloir s'installer à mes côtés je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]